pour de nombreuses tâches l'humain est
plus performant que la machine mais au
fil des siècles les machines n'ont cessé
de rattraper leur retard et ce n'est pas
étonnant
les machines sont plus puissante
physiquement elles peuvent stocker
l'information de manière plus fiable
plus durable et en plus grande quantité
elles sont capables de communiquer à
travers le monde en quelques
millisecondes et avec un débit
d'information énorme et surtout les
machines calcul vite elle calcule même
super vite
pendant que mon cerveau de primates
galère à faire plus de deux ou trois
opérations par seconde
mon téléphone peut-on effectuer des
milliards ceci dit pour l'instant
certaines facultés humaines comme le bon
sens la créativité ou la capacité
d'apprentissage demeure hors de portée
des machines pour l'instant mais depuis
quelques années une révolution semble
s'être mise en place et cette révolution
a été incarné par un algorithme
d'apprentissage appelé le type learning
en particulier en 2012
le type learning a stupéfait tout le
monde de la recherche en explosant les
performances de toutes les autres
méthodes dans une compétition de
reconnaissance d'objets sur une image
alors que les autres méthodes plafonné à
un taux d'erreur de 25%
le diplôme ning réussi à faire chuter ce
taux à 16%
sauf que ledit planning de domino ce
n'était qu'un premier jet l'année
suivante toutes les meilleures équipes
s'étaient mises au dip learning les taux
d'erreur chuté à 14 7,3 6,6 puis 5,7
pour cent
plus étonnant encore le type learning
est désormais sûre humains en
reconnaissance d'image
autrement dit si vous croyez voir un
fantôme et si ledit plan digne champion
d'imagina te dis qu'il s'agit de fumer
je vais davantage faire confiance aux
diplômés alors je dis ça sur le ton de
la blague avec un exemple un peu débile
mais il s'agit en fait là de quelque
chose d'incroyablement profond et dont
les conséquences sociétales vont être
énormes
année après année l'ensemble des tâches
ou humain surpasse la machine fond comme
neige au soleil
après les échecs en 1997 les machines se
sont mises à surpasser les meilleurs
d'entre nous a tout plein d'autres jeux
que ce soit jeopardy
le jeu de go le poker d'autres machines
ont su apprendre à jouer aux jeux vidéo
atari ou à des jeux comme super mario
world
mario kart ou dota 2 et atteindre des
performances souvent surhumaine
est ce qu'il y à d'impressionnants pour
ces jeux c'est que les machines sont
partis de rien moment de prendre les
commandes tout ce qu'elle voyait c'était
les couleurs des pixels à l'écran
les machines ont elles mêmes a appris
les règles de ces jeux puis les bonnes
stratégies à suivre alors les machines
gameuses a priori c'est pas ça qui va
bouleverser nos sociétés en revanche on
ne peut pas en dire autant d'autres
nations qui se sont affairés à remplacer
le travail humain à commencer par les
véhicules autonomes
cela fait déjà plusieurs années que de
nombreuses voitures autonomes sillonne
les routes aux quatre coins du monde et
voiture tesla ont même déjà un système
autonome sur autoroute que les usagers
peuvent activer depuis 2015 en france la
législation autorise la circulation de
voitures entièrement autonome dans le
cadre de procédures de test et le 2
octobre dernier en 2017
4 renault zoé électriques autonomes ont
circulé à roy
plus surprenant encore jean louis
missika adjoint de la maire de paris
affirme que des opérateurs prévoient
déjà expérimenté des taxis autonome dès
2018 et en fait ça fait déjà plus d'un
an que des bus autonomes sont en
fonctionnement ou quatre coins du monde
alors oui ces véhicules autonomes ne
sont pas et ne seront jamais parfait
mais la question ce n'est pas de savoir
s'ils seront parfaits il s'agit de
savoir s'ils seront meilleurs que des
conducteurs humain or les connecteurs
humains sont en fait super mauvaises en
2016 3477 sont mortes par accident de la
route sur les routes françaises du coup
si les véhicules autonomes sont ne
serait ce que deux fois moins létal que
les conducteurs humain ne pas légaliser
reviendrait à tuer des milliers de
personnes par an et ce rien qu'en france
sauf que bien sûr légaliser les
véhicules autonomes
c'est aussi mettre fin à de nombreux
métiers du transport des centaines de
milliers de jobs sont directement
menacés sans compter ceux qui dépendent
directement de l'industrie du transport
d'où l'urgence de repenser notre système
de redistribution des richesses
peut-on que les métiers du transport ne
sont pas la seule cible les machines
managers ingénieurs médecins avocats
artistes chercheurs professeurs et même
youtube heures tous semblent voués à
être surpassée par les machines
d'ailleurs certains métiers qualifiés
ont déjà partiellement disparu c'est le
cas par exemple des traders dont le
coeur de métier a déjà été
essentiellement remplacés par des
machines
et oui parce que ces machines sont
capables d'acheter et de vendre bien
avant qu'un trader humains n'ait eu le
temps de cligner de l'oeil
les machines ont conquis les entrepôts
d'amazon elles se sont mis à construire
des maisons et des ponts
ainsi qu'à planter des légumes et à les
faire pousser et je ne pense pas avoir
besoin de mentionner les productions à
la chaîne le métier d'ouvrier est en
train de partir en fumée
non pas parce que les entreprises sont
d'horribles monstres qui préfèrent
licencier leurs employés plutôt que les
exploiter mais parce que les incentives
l'automatisation sont énormes
les machines sont plus rapides plus
fiables et beaucoup moins cher elles ne
se plaignent jamais et ne sont jamais en
grève
elles permettent de produire en quantité
et en qualité un coup ridiculement
faible mais ce n'est là qu'un début
contrairement à une idée reçue même dans
des métiers qui semble requérir un
jugement subjectif que l'on pourrait
croire nécessairement une la machine sur
passe lentement mais sûrement les
compétences humaines la gaude line
technology a conquis le monde du
football
bien que celui ci ait longtemps résisté
aux technologies il n'est pas
inconcevable qu'un jour les arbitres
soient remplacés par des machines dont
on pourra plus facilement garantir
l'impartialité
d'ailleurs cette mécanisation de
l'arbitrage a déjà commencé dans le
monde de la gymnastique les métiers du
droit pourra suivre cette tendance aussi
on l'a vu le côté juge
les billets sont énormes à commencer par
le fait que le juge ait bien manger ou
non remplacer les juges par des machines
pourraient là aussi garantir davantage
d'impartialité
d'autant que les progrès des machines
dans ce domaine sont énormes mais ce
n'est pas tout la machine caisse
cruncher a ainsi battu les humains dans
une compétition de prédiction de l'issue
d'un processus légal
pendant ce temps à jambi morgan ce sont
360 mille heures de travail humain
d'avocats qu'une machine a su effectuer
en seulement quelques secondes et ce
avec une fiabilité supérieure à celle
des avocats humain une autre machine
encore appelée do not be vous donne dès
aujourd'hui des conseils juridiques pour
éviter de payer des amendes de
stationnement selon son créateur
cette machine réussi à annuler 375000
amende
en l'espace de deux ans l'industrie du
droit représente des milliards d'euros
par an une large proportion de cette
industrie pourrait disparaître dans les
années à venir
les machines deviendront aussi nos
médecins de demain certaines machines
chirurgien d'ores et déjà beaucoup plus
fiable que les chirurgiens humain mais
surtout le gros du travail du médecin et
le diagnostic médical qui consiste à
analyser des symptômes et des données
physiologiques pour un ferrer les
maladies probable or des machines ont
déjà surpassé l'humain dans le
diagnostic de plusieurs maladies comme
le cancer de la peau à partir d'une
photo où celui des arythmies cardiaques
mieux encore les machines du futur
pourront accéder à bien d'autres données
auxquelles les médecins d'aujourd'hui
n'ont pas accès que ce soit la
concentration en temps réel de notre
sens en glucose en cholestérol ou en
d'autres produits chimiques mais aussi
les dernières avancées de la recherche
médicale
alors on pourrait croire que ces
machines seront incapables de faire
preuve d'empathie ou de contacts humains
sauf que les machines ont en fait déjà
surpassé les humains dans l'analyse des
sentiments d'autrui
à partir de son visage les machines
seront davantage capable de s'adapter à
notre humeur et ainsi nous aider à nous
remonter le moral ou a délivré au mieux
une mauvaise nouvelle
oui a tendance à oublier à quel point on
est mauvais quand il s'agit de
comprendre ce que l'autre ressent ou
subis notamment lorsque l'eau liga non
nous surgi
ce n'est donc pas si difficile de faire
mieux que lui non de la même manière on
a tendance à penser que seuls l'humain
est capable de ressentir l'élégance des
oeuvres artistiques
sauf que dans ce domaine aussi la
machine est en train d'atteindre des
performances surhumaine
typiquement la musique que vous entendez
en ce moment c'est une musique composée
et jouée par une machine appelée jupe
tech et ce gratuitement et en
exclusivité pour cette vidéo les
machines ont aussi appris à peindre et à
dessiner voir à reconnaître nos dessins
mieux encore une machine appelée deep
art est capable de combiner n'importe
laquelle de vos photos avec le style
d'un grand peintre pour ainsi créer une
oeuvre d'art inédite face aux progrès
spectaculaires des machines de nombreux
observateurs se sont mis à encourager
l'éducation de masse pour acquérir des
compétences encore inaccessibles aux
machines sauf qu'à bien y réfléchir même
des métiers qui nécessitent des
décennies d'études ne sont pas immunisés
contre les machines
de nos jours les machines sont partout
dans les sciences de la recherche de
molécules pour soigner des maladies à
l'analyse des données des accélérateurs
de particules
en passant par la reconstitution des
circuits du cerveau humain ou par
l'observation des profondeurs du cosmos
les informaticiens sont même en train de
chercher à doter leurs machines de
capacité à prouver des théorèmes et de
nombreuses preuves sont d'ores et déjà
largement assistés par des machines aux
compétences surhumaine et les
informaticiens ne s'arrête pas là ils
cherchent même automatiser leur propre
métier en domptant leurs machines de
capacité à générer leur propre code
étant donné par exemple une simple
spécifications de ce que le code doit
faire ou encore il dote leurs machines
de capacité à réparer d'autres machines
voir à s'auto répare et même les métiers
de chercheurs et de développeurs
pourraient un jour être automatisées et
il en va de même de celui de youtube
heures au japon une combinaison d'une
machine et d'humains a ainsi déjà réussi
à soumettre un manuscrit récompensés par
des humains l'écriture de scripts qui
est le gros de mon boulot sur youtube
pourrait donc bientôt être automatisés
reste à passer devant la caméra me direz
vous mais encore les progrès sont
spectaculaires
la machine web net de google est ainsi
capable de synthétiser des voix
indiscernable de voies naturelles tandis
que des technologies permettent de caler
une voix
image même si la voix ne correspond pas
à l'image cardio si j'ose plus troublant
encore il est désormais possible de
fabriquer en temps réel une image de
n'importe qui prononce en n'importe quel
discours ici vous ne disposez pas de
bonne image de la personne en question
pas de souci d'autres machines sont
capables d'améliorer la résolution
d'image pourtant très pixélisé hu tout
ça de nous vertige mais vers quelle on
se dirige-t-on en fait si le futur que
je n'ai pas nous paraissent différent du
présent c'est surtout parce qu'on a
tendance à mal se rendre compte à quel
point le monde ati a changé au cours des
dernières décennies
aujourd'hui les machines nous ont
encerclés les algorithmes de facebook
youtube et netflix décide en grande
partie de ce que nous lisons et
regardons gmail va même jusqu'à décidé
de masquer automatiquement les spams
tandis que google est notre porte
d'entrée au monde de l'internet et même
ce que nous écrivons est suggérée par
l'auto complétion de nos téléphones
les machines se charge aussi de
planifier des rencontres amoureuses
d'affecter des étudiants à des
formations post-bac de suggérer des
candidats pour des postes en entreprise
pour voir ou encore de gérer ce qui
auparavant était un énorme bordel
administratif
les machines ont déjà envahi notre
quotidien et personne n'a vraiment le
contrôle de cette invasion
alors dis comme
paraître effrayant mais il faut aussi
voir que l'on s'est tant fait volontiers
le pouvoir ou machines et ça c'est parce
que dans de nombreux cas qu'il s'agisse
de ce que youtube nous suggère de ce que
gmail classe dans les spams ou des
véhicules autonomes qui nous ramèneront
chez nous quand tout sera complètement
saoul ces machines nous rendent service
est la clé pour nous rendre service
c'est la recherche en intelligence
artificielle et en machine learning
alors il ya un débat récurrent que de
déterminer la différence entre les deux
franchement perso je dirais aux f
j'aime bien notamment la remarque de
willis c'est de l'intelligence
artificielle pour lever des fonds et du
machine learning pour recruter par
contre une distinction qui me semblent
importantes à faire est celle entre
recherche appliquée et recherche
théorique
le problème des applications aujourd'hui
c'est que tout va très très très très
vite et que du coup ce qui est l'état de
l'art aujourd'hui peut tout à fait
devenir obsolète dans un an
donc dans cette série et contrairement à
ce qu'a fait dans ce premier épisode on
va surtout parler des aspects théoriques
de l'intelligence artificielle de sorte
que les prochains épisodes resteront
valables et pertinent je l'espère dans
cinq dix ou vingt ans pour ce faire je
vais surtout un pied sur deux livres le
livre de standing machine learning from
three to application de chat laisse
choir et une peine david et le livre
diplôme ning de benjo goodfellow et
courville et puis dans les premiers
épisodes de cette série je m'appuierai
aussi beaucoup sur l'article de 1950
d'alan turing parce que c'est
certainement l'un des articles les plus
fous de l'histoire
et puis je vous recommande aussi les
vidéos que j'ai fait en anglais avec des
professeurs de le pfl sur la chaîne zeta
bike
j'espère que ce premier épisode au mode
un petit heures vous aura vraiment donné
envie de voir cette série sur
intelligence artificielle la prochaine
fois on parlera d'intelligent si on se
demandera si une machine peut posséder
l'intelligence humaine
si vous avez aimé cet épisode pensez à
cliquer à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour noter les
futurs épisodes marseille tipper power
nom et j'espère que vous serez là des
prochaines fois cette accélération
exponentielle dont je vous parle la
raison pour laquelle vous dis que ça
arrive tout de suite on a du mal à la
voir c'est difficile de la voir
c'est difficile parce que notre cerveau
il fonctionne en mode linéaire il a
tendance à penser que ce qui va arriver
les deux prochaines années
ça arrivera au même rythme que les deux
dernières années en réalité c'est
cumulatif et ça s'accélère à une vitesse
exponentielle
si on avait dit à nos ancêtres il ya
cent ans que qu'à l'avenir vous serez
capables de se parler se voir dans le
creux de la main à deux endroits de la
planète différents
j'aurais pris pour des fous
[Musique]